hey youtubers is Charlie so this week
for my Game of Thrones bonus video I
wanted to talk about the top 10
characters that I'd like to see come
back on the show like confirmed dead
characters that I want back Charles
dance totally tease that we might not
have seen the last Tywin Lannister so
I'll also kind of explain what he was
talking about george RR martin is
definitely one of the best at teasing
the potential to see old characters
again you know whether it be flashbacks
resurrection or just straight-up
reanimation really important reminder to
anyone that's new world of Ice and Fire
the new book that's coming out is here
at the end of the month so I'll be
giving away some extra copies whenever
it gets here so be sure to subscribe to
get all that stuff but now my top 10
characters that I want back careful for
spoilers for everything through season 4
on the show I'll wait just a sec ok
everybody ready here we go number 10 the
Giants killed during the sack of Castle
black I feel like we'd all like to see
some zombie giants they don't make it
very clear but the giant the gren killed
in the tunnel was Magda mighty Giants
don't have kings but mag was something
of a leader to the remaining Giants the
only other one that Martin has written
about specifically that he's given a
name to is one one because two giants
died during season four it's possible
that that other one was one one so
there's no promise that we're going to
see more giants in season five but it's
possible especially if they get
reanimated by White Walkers number nine
Renly coming back is a vision to haunt
Loras we haven't seen a lot of ghosts on
the series visions are like the next
best thing I just like the idea of Renly
haunting Loras not in a bad way though
the show is doing a little bit more with
the Loras character than the books did
here's a picture of Finn Jones on the
set of season five they've actually been
filming a lot of King's Landing stuff in
the last couple of weeks we didn't get
to see him ton of Renly on the show
thanks to Melisandre but Renly in the
books is even more nuts with pageantry
so if he did hot lorises dreams I like
to think that he would probably do it
with like a never-ending tourney like he
would just be whispering constantly in
lorises ear just creating some sort of
fictional tournament the way I think
about Renly in the books is being like
this theater geek with almost unlimited
money number eight Grenn the giant
slayer coming back as a white they
burned all the bodies after the second
Castle black so technically this is
impossible
Grenn dying in the tunnel was one of the
big changes the show made to the book
story I feel like he's earned a trip
back although technically that would be
a bad thing for his character like you
don't want him to come back as a white
because he'd be evil the evolution of
gren the giant-slayer is actually pretty
interesting he started out as that
[ __ ] that was bullying Samwell in
season 1 one of the brothers that John
fought off but by the wildling attack of
season 4 he had matured to the point
where he respected everyone because he
gladly gave his life in service of the
brotherhood we fondly remember him as
gren the giant slayer and remember the
giant that he killed was Magda mighty
number 7 Ygritte coming back as a vision
to give Jon Snow advice her body was
also burned so the only way she's coming
back is as a vision or a flashback but
Jon just seems like the kind of
character who is constantly haunted by
spirits least of all his parents both
real and adoptive Ygritte was one of the
few really good guides that he had
although he did have a lot of role
models I feel like he just learned
almost as much with her in his short
time north of the wall as he did in like
all 16 years prior to that I think he's
like 1617 where we are on the show right
now maybe 18 it's only been a couple
years one of the reasons why I really
encourage all of you to read the books
if you haven't is because you just get
to see what's inside his head he's a POV
character in book five I'd really like
to see him conjure up Ygritte as a way
for his subconscious to manifest itself
and give him advice it would be like Jon
telling himself he knows nothing number
six
Khal Drogo as a vision to Daenerys I
just want to see Jason Momoa back on the
show just being crazy he was burned too
so only way he's coming back is in
noncorporeal form Daenerys
kind of looks like she's staying put in
Mereen for the time being but at some
point she's gonna have to March our army
somewhere I'd like to see her conjure up
Khal Drogo as a way to reassure herself
during conquest we really only saw him
for like a small slice of his life
around the wedding in the short journey
to the western coastline he became a cow
because he was such a great warlord like
he was a badass so he probably have some
pretty good advice to give it a battle
number five Kalin Stark reanimated as a
corpse by the red god I feel like this
is obligatory I mean she
mentioning at least not my favorite
character that I'd like to see back but
she still has a really important role in
the greater scheme of the books I'm
actually really interested to see how
the show decides to fill the gap left by
her absence like who are they going to
give this big vengeance arc to I do
think that they dropped her character
I'm not expecting to see her but that
doesn't mean that they dropped the role
that she serves in the narrative number
4 the mountain reanimated as a golem for
cleganebowl it was implied that Qyburn
was getting his frankenstein on in the
season 4 finale so I just like to see
that taken to the next logical step it
also seemed like the show wanted us to
think the Hound was dead too but since
we did not see it happen on screen it's
possible they could bring him back Rory
McCann has not been seen on set yet but
it's still possible for those that have
not seen any of the clogging bull forum
threads it's just the idea that
circumstances could allow for the
mountain and the Hound to face off in a
big epic battle it'd be like their own
version of Oberyn Martell vs. the
mountain except they just hack each
other to pieces there's all kinds of
theories on how this could go down so
maybe I'll just talk about Coe gamble in
a future video it's actually pretty
interesting number 3 Tywin Lannister
reanimated by the red God
recently Charles dance teased that we
might not have seen the last of Tywin I
do not think that means he's coming back
to life on the show I just think we're
gonna get to see the funeral but I would
love to see a twist for the character
whereby he has like a Stannis type arc
where he's co-opted by the red God or
the forces that red God most of the
people in King's Landing think the red
God is either blasphemy or total
[ __ ] little do they know they didn't
see that shadow baby in reality what's
going on with this Tywin thing you have
to remember that new seasons of the show
always pick up in the moments right
after the previous season's finale it
just means that they're gonna address
what happens with the body of the most
powerful man in Westeros but they're
just gonna deal with Tywin's body it
would be pretty ridiculous to see him
come back and when you think about it I
mean he really only had a bunch of
poison swirling around inside him
rotting insides and a few holes in his
chest I mean it's not like half his face
had fallen off number 2 over in Martell
reanimated as a headless corpse I just
want to see him come back is like the
headless horseman of King's Landing
instead of wilting an axe he just
right around on a horse just chopping
off Lannister's heads with his giant
spear it would probably get in the way
of some of the big season five plots but
it'd be really fun to see him turn into
this Kings Landing
urban legend and finally my number one
character that I would like to see come
back Robert Baratheon as a flashback
this is just so we can see what he
learned at the battle that tried it when
he killed Rhaegar Targaryen he was
supposedly the only person to hear his
dying words like it was just the two of
them the rumor goes that when Rhaegar
died he supposedly whispered someone's
name like a woman's name I think it was
Lyanna stark but Martin hasn't really
given any explicit information about
that yet he did say we get more
flashbacks to Robert's rebellion in the
future book so we will eventually learn
what happened let me know though which
confirmed dead characters do you want to
see comeback now remember there are lots
of literary devices for bringing dead
characters back just as a bonus though
I'd like to see flashbacks for the Mad
King and Rhaegar Targaryen but I think
sometimes it's better that they don't do
those things just so my imagination can
fill in the gaps I mean that's why
reading the books can be more fun at
times you just get the chance to imagine
something so much crazier than they're
capable of doing on the show
speaking of which congratulations - I
love popcorn you're this week's giveaway
winner I'll be reaching out to you on
your channel for details but you
basically win your pick of any of
Martin's books so my next bonus video is
going to post next week so be sure to
subscribe to get that I know I talked
about you know a bunch of characters
dying I do have theories about how the
show is going to end so you can click
here to learn more about that and you
can click here to get more of my season
5 predictions thank you so much for
watching so let's all high-five and
we'll meet back up later to talk about
some Gotham
[Music]
you